Hello Welcome to Science Last Week from
Science Mission I am Sadashiv Pay and going to
discuss three papers published in the week of
April 28 Let's
start first we are going to discuss a
paper published by Chris Knight Lab in Nature
Communications
The paper talks about how mutation  Rate in
bacteria is
controlled The findings in this paper are
very important for end disease as authors
Identification
rate is a fundamental factor in evolutionary
genetics in nature Mutation rates are
typically minimized as far as population
genetic constraints
allow rates of expression
with these
genotypes in Ela  And variation in mutation
rates is observed among natural isolates Weather and how
mutation rates at any particular site might vary That is mutation rate
plasticity MRP for given genotype is
of particular
interest MRP can increase during
environmental and genetic
stress using la Author's identification
Rate plasticity in la  k12 Using Fluctuation
Assays
Ten Assays Identification
of Mutation Rates Related to Changing
Absolute Fitness Mutation Rate Doubles with
Every Reduction in Absolute Fitness by
2.6 Absolute Fitness is Affected by Many
Independent Variables and Parameters
Including Culture Volume Inoculum Size
Viability Productivity and Nutrient
Availability Using Various K12
By manipulating the stress response and
evolved culture volume and culture
period we eliminated various hypotheses and
fitted a linear model for mutation rate with population
density as shown in the bottom figure. In other words they found
strong evidence
for an inverse relationship between final population
density on  Mutation
Rate Less Cells More Mutations Authors
Wanted to Identify Rate Lux
Culture with the ancestor Beera
strain, the null luxSmut grows to approximately the same
density as the K122
wild type and has an average a mutation
rate that is not significantly
different, however they observe a significant
difference in the slope of mutation rate in
response to density between  Strains as shown
in figure
A further more the null
luxus mutant showed a response that had a
slope not significantly different from zero indicating that
identification
also shows that only
apert to the medium at levels known to complement the
metabolic defect of the null luxus mutant
stores the density  Dependence on level seen
in the wild
type The bottom figure shows that the conclusion is that
signaling molecules affect
MRPs
to test explicitly while the effect of
the null mutation acts via cell-cell
interaction in cultured cells marked via
chlornil resistance with respect to wild
type K2 and null.  Lux es mutes than
measured mutation rates of reform pson
resistance in the marked fraction of the
population they found that population comparisons
of stress grow to very similar final
population
densities. How ever mutation rates to reform peace
in are dependent strongly on the identity
of  The co-culture strain's overall
population density and average
mutation rate increases by over a
third in the presence of Null access Mut
relative to the presence of wild-type
cells. Thirds also found that the effect of the Null
access Mut may be functionally complemented
by a third  In the medium with
an increase in average mutation
rate this confirms the action of fluxus via
cell cell interaction and the
activation via methyl cycle taken together
it is clear that MRP is dependent upon
the social environment provided by lux
dependent processes Next let's look at
an  Interesting Paper
from Bran One's Lab This Paper Talks About
How Maternal Food Intake Prior to Comp
Conception Results in Epigenetic
Modification in Their
Progeny Let's Look at What is Known About Ape
Genetic Control of
Progeny Evidence is abundant that
environmental factors during early life
have long-term  Effects on Later Health
Outcomes and That These Processes Reflect
Epigenetic Responses to Preconception
Exposure
Multiple cell
types in experimental animals Maternal diet during the
periconceptional period influences the
establishment of DNA
methylation at metastable
alleles in the offspring
with permanent
phenotypic
sexes Several differences in the diet of
rural Guyanese women Ala the authors to test the
hypothesis that in humans
methylation of  M in peripheral blood
lymphocytes T e PBL could be used as read
out of epigenetic state in other tissues Thres major plasma
concentrations of key donor
pathway substrates at one
of the 13 bio markers and two ride variables
show significant differences between
seasons of conception
Maternal preconception concentrations of  Folic
acid vitamin beet methan betan not shown here
and the ratio of s adenosine methan and s
adenosine homo cysteine
and ratio of beet and da methyl glycine
ver higher in rainy season and
concentrations of act beet di methyl
glycine homo cysteine ​​and s adenosine
homo cysteine ​​ver
Lower Next Authors
Tested Weather This Nutrition Driven Seasonal
Differences in Maternal Peri Conception One
Carbon Metabolic
Analysis Establishment of DNA
Mille at Human
M The Mille Analysis Focus on Cell Total Loss
PBL and Her Follicle Support Effect of Mammalian
and Terminal Tissue Respectively from 8
Month old affected bone in mothers in the brain
Main group r use
percent methylation in HF and PBL with
each of the remaining six M was highly
correlated
Important effects of season of concession on
DNA methylation were also correlated in two
tissue groups of spring of Rennie  Season
Comps had higher levels of CpG
methylation at the same time in PBL and overall
effect of season was highly significant. The
seasonal pattern in HF samples was
similar so this is the first in human
confirmation of the human blood bio marker. Sts
of substrate and co factors required
For Methyl Donor Pathways Measured Around the
Time of Conception Pretends the Mile Patterns of A
in Offspring So What Mother Eats Before Conception
Is Important and Plays a Role in
the Offspring's Genetic Information Next Let's Have
a Look at the Paper
Published from Lucas Lab The Paper  Talks About
Using Platelet Serotonin
Transporter as a Measure of Understanding
Brain
Activity Let's Have a Look at the
Literature Serotonin Transporter is
Abundantly Expressed in Humans
and Gene SL c6 A4 Quotes for Serotonin
Transporter Serotonin transporter
removes serotonin from extracellular
space It has been
postlateral ship between platelets  and
Synapto somal Serotonin Re
Uptake But It is Not Known If the Platelet
Serotonin Uptake Can Predict
Neural Activation of Human
Brain
Networks The results in this paper provide a tool
to evaluate brain
activity to understand and also
to do the FC of serotonin transporter
in
Depression to evaluate potential impact of
platelet and MAX on coherent functional
networks through calculated functional
connectivity which provides a robust measure to assess
temporal correlations in the functional
MRI signal across function linked
areas Functional connectivity analysis
explores which parts of the brain are
coupled with a given seed  Region by Cross
Correlating the Time Series of the Seed with All the
Other
Vessels Figures Display Right Hemispheric
Surface Mapping of a Whole Brain Collation
Analysis Between Platelet V Max and
Blood Oxygen Level Dependent T i Bold
Activity Significant Brain Areas Show
Positive and Negative
Collation Negatively Collated  Clusters Compra
Area of ​​the Default Mode Network That Is DM N Sach S
Regus Within the Me Prefrontal
Cortex Anterior Singlet Cortex as Well
as Posterior Singlet Cortex Middle Temporal
Gyr and Inferior Temporal Gyr
Positive Corrosion Were Found in the Frontoparietal
Cut Control
System That is the  Central executive
network and salience network with the
significant cluster located in the right
motor cortex and premotor cortex
Scatter plot on the left shows a negative
relationship between Platelet and Max and
BOLD activity averages across the medial
prefrontal cortex
Cluster scatter plot on the right shows a
positive relationship between  Platelet
Vmax and BOLD Activity Average Across the
Motor Cortex
Cluster So This Study Demonstrates that
Platelet Vmax may be used as a useful
tool to understand the brain activity
under normal and altered conditions like
depression Thank you for watching Science Last
Week from Science Mission